un ambiente festivo en este remoto
estadio de doja transformado en un infan
son durante el torneo mundialista un
espacio reservado las trabajadores
inmigrantes de Qatar que constituyen el
90% de su población de India bangladesh
en nepal sri lanka y Pakistán ganan un
máximo de 250 euros al mes insuficiente
para poder permitirse una entrada para
ver los partidos que ronda entre los 60
y los 200 euros en esta primera etapa de
la competición
toda la gente Está disfrutando aquí pero
yo no tengo ninguna posibilidad ninguna
posibilidad de entrar en el estadio solo
vengo aquí solo puedo disfrutar bueno
entre los 15.000 que acudieron a la zona
de aficionados esta tarde muchos
vinieron a apoyar a Argentina y a su
delantero estrella Lionel Messi
una breve oportunidad para desahogarse
entre largos nocturnos
[Música]
durante 14 horas y llegó una hora tarde
Así que tengo que ir rápido a trabajar
pero estoy contento ya está han ganado
he ganado estoy contento puedo trabajar
14 horas sí
Qatar dice que ha mejorado las
condiciones laborales de sus
trabajadores migrantes Pero según varias
ongs el maltrato sigue siendo una
práctica habitual en febrero una
investigación del diario británico de
Garden reveló que 6.500 migrantes había
muerto en las obras de construcción
cataríes en el país se han construido
siete estadios tres líneas de metro y un
aeropuerto en un tiempo
récord para el mundial más caro de
la historia